also Leute was langsam nervt ist die
Frage guckst du die WM und noch mehr
nerven so verdrucks die Antworten wie
die hier die Frage habe ich befürchtet
keine Ahnung
gucken oder boykottieren ist die große
moralfrage wobei die wm-cooker Client
Nachteil sind gucken geht inzwischen
moralisch als mindestens so fragwürdig
wie sagen wir Kurzstrecke fliegen oder
Skifahren auf Kunstschnee was ich daran
erstaunlich finde wie wir schaffen das
ist am Ende wieder vor allem um uns geht
darum wie es Dir oder mir dabei geht
wenn wir gucken oder eben nicht gucken
also wer das sein achtsamkeitseminar
aber klar die Politik macht es ja vor da
lautet die Frage hinfahren oder
boykottieren eigentlich aber sind beide
Fragen gar nicht zu entscheiden viel
wichtiger ist was anderes und darum geht
es in diesem inside politics ich erzähle
euch warum wir aufhören müssen uns mit
Nebensächlichkeiten zu beschäftigen und
auf die Dinge schauen müssen die und
jetzt kommt viel mehr Einfluss auf Euch
auf mich auf uns alle haben werden was
lehrt uns diese WM über die Welt darüber
wie sich die Gewichte verschieben und
über unseren Platz und unsere Zukunft
kurz vor der WM bin ich mit
Innenministerin Faser nach Katar gereist
die Innenministerin fand die WM-Vergabe
nach Katar seinen Fehler Katha fand das
zu sagen sein Fehler und wollte von ihr
noch vor der Reise eine Erklärung die
Innenministerin war ziemlich angespannt
das spürte ich also in Katar ankam und
nicht Ausstieg fühlte sie so an als
würde ich in eine schwule Wand laufen so
heiß war es da irgendwie muss ich an
Peking denken da was genau so heiß im
Sommer 2008 da waren Olympische Spiele
dort die waren übrigens genauso
umstritten wie jetzt die wir in Katar
diejenigen die damals die Spiele in
Peking verteidigten verbanden damit
riesige Hoffnungen
lange hat China davon geträumt seine
Tore zu öffnen und die Sportler aus
aller Welt begrüßen zu dürfen zu den
Olympischen Spielen von Peking heute
Abend wird aus diesem Traum Wirklichkeit
ich gratuliere Peking
die Hoffnung auf Reformen auf Öffnung
vielleicht sogar Liberalisierung das
höre ich jetzt wieder bei Katha zum
Beispiel vom ehemaligen Außenminister
Sigmar Gabriel der schreibt auf Twitter
die deutsche Arroganz gegenüber Katha
ist zum kotzen meint er wohl Fortschritt
kommt nicht über Nacht sondern Schritt
für Schritt findet Gabriel das galt für
Deutschland und gilt euch jetzt für Kata
die UNO die ILO loben das Land für seine
Reform nur wir Deutschen beleidigen ist
jeden Tag man muss dazu sagen dass
Gabriel das selbst ganz gut kann das
beleidigen oder beleidigt sein aber
vielleicht hat er recht vielleicht
bringt die WM Formen nach Katar
vielleicht wird Katha tatsächlich zu
einer Oase von Öffnung und
Liberalisierung in der
menschenrechtswüste der arabischen
Halbinseln die Leute von der ILO die
Gabriel erwähnt hat Ferse übrigens
gleich als erstes getroffen
ILO steht für internationale
arbeitsorganisationen ist eine Agentur
der UNO in Katha kümmert sie sich um die
Rechte der Wanderarbeiter die vor allem
aus Südostasien kommen die haben unter
desaströsen Bedingungen zum Beispiel die
WM Stadien gebaut die
ILO findet dass es Reformschritte in
kattergab aber das auch noch viel zu tun
sei es not a black and white shades of
grey and Portugal roll is ready context
to tell the journey that's the best for
five years with sign of cards how that
be implemented
und die mindestens 6500 Wanderer bei der
die nach Recherchen des Guardian seit
der WM-Vergabe in Katha gestorben sind
die Elo sagt die Zahl beinhalte alle
Todesfälle in diesem Zeitraum ist der
unklar wie viele davon mit der Arbeit
auf den Baustellen zusammenhängen das
stimmt aber die Zahl bleibt verstörend
hoch weine nicht die Zahl der Todesfälle
von Arbeiten z.B von den Philippinen da
noch gar nicht drin sind und Katas
Regierung hilft schon überhaupt nicht
bei der Aufklärung Transparenz mag sie
nicht so gern es gibt Wissenschaftler
die haben untersucht ob es ein
Zusammenhang gibt zwischen Sport
Veranstaltungen und politischen Reformen
deren Ergebnis ist eher ernüchternd aus
dem bisherigen Erfahrungen von Sport
Großveranstaltungen autoritären Regime
müssen wir leider feststellen dass so
eine Liberalisierung nicht erwartbar ist
insgesamt muss man sagen ist die Bilanz
solcher Turniere sehr negativ das in
China nichts draus wurde aus Reformen
und Liberalisierung sah man spätestens
Anfang dieses Jahres als wieder
Olympische Spiele in Peking waren
diesmal Winterspiele alles war
abgeschirmt in einer Zero Corvette Blase
und das Land selbst war viel unfrei als
2008 geradewegs auf dem Weg in eine
totalitäre Diktatur und in Katha fazer
will bei ihrer Reise dort
Sicherheitsgarantien für deutsche Fans
und glaubt dass sie die vom
Premierminister dann auch bekommen hat
also er hat gesagt dass er alles dafür
tun wird dass die Sicherheit der
Menschen garantiert wird und auch zwar
mit dieser Formulierung egal an wen man
glaubt egal wie man liebt mir egal wo
man herkommt ist sie zurück werden in
einer zdf-doku
feindliche Äußerungen von Katas
wm-botschafter bekannt es ist taram also
verboten aber warum ist es heran es ist
ein geistiger schaden
nicht das einzige was passiert beim
ehemaligen Kommunikationschef des
WM-Organisationskomitee ist der ins
Gefängnis kam weil er sich für die
Belange der Wanderarbeiter einsetzte bei
dem verschärft hat das Regierung jetzt
die Haftbedingungen er darf noch nicht
mal seine Frau sehen kurz vor der WM
verhärtet sich also der Ton in Katar man
findet dort offenbar jetzt haben wir
eigentlich genug getan Kritik finden die
Kataris im Moment genauso zum Kotzen wie
Sigmar Gabriel hier der Chef von Katar
Airways zum Beispiel
negative Medienkampagne gegen mein
geliebtes Land Katar
wenn die Menschen können nicht
akzeptieren dass ein kleines Land wie
der Staat Katar das größte Sportereignis
der Welt gewonnen hat
es ist als ob die konservativen Kräfte
wieder Aufwind haben oder vielleicht
immer hatten wie viel also sind die
reformversprechender Wert oder die
Sicherheitsgarantien für deutsche Fans
wenn wir sozusagen Sicherheitsgarantien
aussprechen müssen für eine
Sportveranstaltung dann ist es doch
offensichtlich dass dieses Land nicht
dafür gemacht ist meine persönliche
Meinung ist dass wir diplomatisch
boykottieren sollten das
Kabinettsmitglieder nicht reisen sollten
also wenn das irgendeinen Unterschied
macht also wenn das irgendjemand
Interessierte in Wahrheit zeigt doch die
Frage dass die Länder Deutschlands das
auf Werte pocht aber Energie und
Unterstützung braucht im Sommer
vergangenen Jahres zum Beispiel Kater
soll die Taliban überzeugen Menschen aus
Afghanistan flüchten zu lassen im März
dann kommt Harbeck mit seiner tiefen
Verbeugung im September Scholz und
diesmal lautet die Bitte Katha soll
helfen das Gas aus Russland zu setzen
auch der Fußball lässt Deutschland kühl
auflaufen FIFA Präsidentin fantino der
lobt sich und die FIFA Menschen
Geschäftspolitik und kaum sind die
Deutschen Weg forderte in einen Brief an
die teilnehmenden Verbände Schluss mit
der Politik konzentrieren wir uns jetzt
auf den Fußball es ist wie damals 2018
Peking ein mächtiger Sportverband der
trotz aller Fähren und Korrumpiertheit
seiner Funktionäre macht was er will und
ein aufstrebendes reiches Land das der
Welt zeigen will wie wichtig und
mächtiges geworden ist in China wurde
Deutschland von diesem riesigen Markt
profitieren jetzt bei Katha wollen wir
billiges Flüssiggas und von den
Sportverbänden hätten wir am Ende auch
gerne so einen schönen Wettbewerb oder
zum Beispiel die
Fußball-Europameisterschaft 2024 ist sie
genau in Deutschland deshalb nervt mich
diese Frage so guckst du oder guckst du
nicht weil das ehrlich gesagt total egal
ist rate mal wie hoch die
Einschaltquoten bei Chinas Winterspielen
in diesem Jahr waren wollten ja auch
viele boykottieren oder genau die waren
ungefähr so hoch wie die bei den
Sommerspielen in Tokio kein
boykott-unterschied kann gut sein dass
es bei WM genauso kommt wenn erstmal der
Ball rollt und die Deutschen nicht so
schlecht spielen wie man befürchten muss
die verrennen uns in nebensächlichen
Fragen und machen uns gleichzeitig
abhängig von jenen die wir eigentlich
boykottieren wollen der FIFA und Cutter
dem IOC und China wir machen schon
wieder den gleichen Fehler zweimal nach
was drei oder viermal wer wirklich was
erreichen will mit seiner Kritik der
muss schon schauen dass er selbst stark
und unabhängig ist Bittsteller sein und
erhobener Zeigefinger das klappt nicht
oder was meint ihr sagt es mir schreibt
es uns wir sind gespannt auf eure
Meinung